que signifient ces le premier sourire
quand vous arrivez 30 ans pendant
lesquels les gens arrivent et sortez
passé dans le tunnel est passé de leur
côté voilà je me trouve dans un endroit
particulièrement émotionnant de notre
monde actuel
c'est le mur qui sépare le mexique dans
la ville de tijuana avec les états unis
d'amérique
c'est un symbole de notre époque de
l'impasse de notre époque le lin pas du
système dominant de notre époque comme
l'a été le mur de berlin le symbole de
l'impasse d'un régime politique
mais non c'est pour les détracteurs
hoon est chaude est sa nature à l'esad
et à l'amplitude comme ethos temps
barbares qui tente et sous pilote
fondamentalement fait c'est construire
ou moureaux personnes qu'elle a chanté
une augmentation pour qu'ils vendent pas
sa mort vient de souffrir nos héros
pasaran entre nous tu as comme en face
au sida sont capables ou non les
cocktails à l'eau qui viennent
intégra russia leurs processeurs
migrants d
[Applaudissements]